we are suspending
open and concealed carry I think it's
time to talk about the absoluteness of
the discussion on the current Court
actions that suggests that the Second
Amendment is an absolute right and none
of the others are no constitutional
right in my view including my oath
is intended to be absolute
New Mexico's Democratic governor being
called out for her Crackdown on the
Second Amendment including by some in
her own parties and some of the most
liberal members of her party the
governor announcing a 30-day ban on
concealed carry firearms for
self-defense she claims it is a
necessary response to gun violence after
declaring it a public health emergency
gun rights Advocates say it puts the
community in danger
[Music]
that right away
everyone here I see no criminals I see
law abiding citizens where the executive
in this state does not have the ability
to willfully violate your rights so use
your
user everyone here should sue this on
yourself
I think we're out here
we don't have
[Applause]
two State lawmakers immediately called
for the Governor's impeachment and
Democratic congressman Ted Liu says the
move is unconstitutional even gun
control activist David Hogg is pushing
back saying quote there is no such thing
as a state public health emergency
except to the U.S Constitution and yet
she persists Harold she was on the short
list of bidens to be VP in 2020 I'm sure
the Dem base will love this is she
making a play
I don't know what she's doing but I'll
tell you this I I'm a little contrary on
this about her I think she's
unconstitutional what she's suggesting
and likely would be challenged and in
court obviously and likely struck down I
like when politicians are big and
creative sometimes I'm gonna disagree
with them people disagree with that but
for sending the migrants to these cities
that's gotten us to a point of where we
are talking about the things that we're
talking about now when it comes to the
Border when Trump talked about uh
possibly attacking the cartels in Mexico
or in South America uh people said to
look you can't do that but it's making
us think and perhaps we should be
thinking more creatively or sitting the
military to the Border we have a Public
Health crisis in this country with guns
that doesn't mean that I'm not a second
amendment guy but the reality is when
you see kids being shot in schools and
the kind of gang Warfare we see in our
cities we've got to begin to think
bigger and more creatively this won't
this won't go this won't pass
constitutional muster but it's going to
make us think long and hard about
perhaps some of the other things some of
the additional measures constitutional
measures we can take to try to reduce
violence in our communities across the
country so I don't think they're going
to go very far with this Governor but I
give you salute for thinking big and
being bold well
what's the point that they declare
emergencies for more government control
Jesse and then when they say it helps
their base get excited about it and then
the base finds out is not constitutional
and then they get mad like student loans
well even the base knows it's nuts when
David Hogg says something's nuts it's
really nuts
if the Republicans were smart we're not
saying they are but if they were they
would win the next election just on this
alone seize on this and capitalize on it
Kamala Harris officiated This Woman's
wedding
she was the head of the Democrat
Governors Association chair of the
Hispanic caucus she's been in the house
this is no nobody Fringe wackadoodle
this is a legit Democrat a national
Democrat so to go out there and say that
and then just pretend like it doesn't
happen you make the Democratic party own
this this is the farthest the Democratic
party has ever reached on guns this goes
farther than any this goes farther than
the assault weapons ban than anything
and I did a deep dive into this woman
didn't want to but I had to she has no
ethics you know what she did she settled
the case for about 80 grand she poured a
bottle of water on the staffers Crotched
and then slapped him in his crotch in
front of a bunch of people settled then
she raided some emergency fund in her
office and bought wagyu sticks with it
bought booze thousands of dollars and
then took these foreign junkets that
were financed by some sleazy autocrat
this woman has no ethics at all her
phone number and also there was some
covet hygin oh she's got hijinks at the
Wazoo Dana and
she doesn't care about the Constitution
and she's admitting she doesn't care and
that's why you have to pin that tail on
the donkey okay literally that's very
good Jesse hey if they if the Democrats
think this is reasonable then that means
that somebody like Governor Ron DeSantis
could declare an emergency and just
change the laws of the nation I've had
enough of people declaring emergencies
in order to take control of Our Lives I
know that mass shootings are bad but if
we're going to do the numbers then let's
do the numbers okay it's exceedingly
rare compared to car fatalities why
don't we declare emergencies on that we
can declare emergencies on anything this
is it's part of a bigger problem that
we're seeing unfold permission to go
Alex Jones
[Laughter]
this 30-day suspension of a
constitutional right is meant to be a
trial balloon right a test for something
that may happen in the next year in the
run-up to the election saying that the
Second Amendment is not absolute and
then having a few gun control Fanatics
so hold on that's that's theater you got
Trump Trump's I feel like he's going to
go to jail you're seeing parents being
cleaved from their kids with this bill
in California free speech that's the
it's not just the Second Amendment you
got the First Amendment there's a number
of examples of free speech being
um flexible right you know if you could
lose your medical license you know if
you decide to say something different
about coven we now know that the
government did suppress try to suppress
uh information First Amendment uh um so
that people wouldn't speak out against
what they believed to be right you have
to read these retail theft laws you know
the 900 uh ceiling that's another trial
balloon for the end of private property
in my uh the conspiracy tutorial of
theater
you can see these all kind of go
together you're you're seeing an attack
on speech you're seeing an attack on
personal protection if you get mugged I
mean look at the guy in the subway who
tried to save people's lives if you look
at theft and in private property I have
a feeling that this timing is strange
here and it might get very weird I think
this next election will make the other
two I don't know look like a game of
pickleball among friends I mean why
would you suspend the Second Amendment
so and this is where I become Alex Jones
so military militarized action will
succeed without friction stage and
events call a clamp down disarm the
public very good thank you judge does it
drive you crazy that people who are in
positions where they're up they swear to
uphold the Constitution come up with
things like this because when you were a
judge I'm sure you would have liked to
have been able to say this is what Judge
Jeanine would do but you had to follow
the law
well yeah you know I don't know what's
more shocking This Woman's ignorance or
her arrogance uh and and both come into
play here she is ignorant of the law in
a country where she is the chief
executive of the State uh she is
ignorance of her oath which requires
that she uphold the Constitution uh she
is ignorant of the Supreme Court
decisions that are are fundamental to
the Second Amendment the first being
um what are we talking about uh Bruin
the New York case it just said within
the last two years that New Yorkers have
the right to carry a firearm outside of
their home when some nut Governor like
Cuomo tried to say you can't bring him
out of your home then Heller against DC
they said the Supreme Court said it's
not just for militia you could use a gun
for self-defense and then McDonald
against the city of Chicago 14th
Amendment uh applies uh uh to the
individual in the state carry gun look
this is 5 fundamental law in the United
States and the Democrats from your
example which was perfect we're going to
use an executive order we're going to
get rid of all of the student loan debt
you people are not dictate I mean you
are dictators but you don't have the
authority to do this one of the things
that she says she's trying to do is stop
crying well what are you doing about
stopping crime how about you make some
arrests how about you get rid of this uh
cashless bail law how about we make sure
we put more money into the police
department how about we close more cases
and by the way you say that the Genesis
of this is three kids who got shot have
there been people arrested in those
cases now you want to take the legal gun
owner and I want to end it with this one
thing which really blew me away she's
now got some kind of state Regulators
who are going to take stats and those
stats are going to be on every crime
with a gun the type of gun the brand the
caliber of the gun so then she's going
to come out with a report and say this
gun is nine millimeters Sig Sauer
whatever it might be is a gun that's
responsible for more murders than any
other gun again taking away the
individual responsibility but nowhere in
her stats is the assessment of whether
the gun is legal or illegal and I would
recommend Governor that you throw that
in there because I'll bet most of these
murders are happening with illegal guns
stop trying to take them away from legal
gun owners she has opened up Pandora's
boxes this will be one of our
Thanksgiving dinner conversations can't
wait all right police still frantically
searching for an escape killer in
Pennsylvania after he narrowly evaded
capture we have the very latest on it
next hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else